[Music]  you're living the dreams DP yeah  devil-may-care stronk eyes beautiful  girlfriend  sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the  gluten in the world and launching in a  space where it can't not hurt us ever  again kiss me like you missed me read  what in the ass  my name's cable I'm here for the kid  what the kid movie guy  kids give us a chance to be better than  we used to be he needs you  a lot smarter than I look  net cable kill this kid but I can't do  this alone  we're gonna form a super duper group  that's what we're gonna be  forward-thinking gender neutral we will  be known as x-force you're absolutely  right now  cue the music  tell me they got that in slow motion  doing the right thing is messy you want  to fight for what's right to fight dirty  that is why the man bun is just a  millennial mullet oh god I wish I  finished college it lives up to the hype  plus bus they probably won't even make  it three yeah why would they stop it -  you killed it  [Music]